The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GARY GENSLER: Thank you
for everybody coming back.
And I should tell
you, when I start
the session with
that little shh,
I learned from a
congressman in Baltimore.
As some of you know, I've spent
a lot of time around politics.
And one of my roles
in politics was
that I was the treasurer of
the Maryland Democratic Party.
Which, if you
anybody ever asks you
to be the treasurer of
a state party, come.
I can give you some
advice about what
that's all about
when your home state
senator asks you to do it.
So I had to quiet down the
annual Jefferson Jackson Day
dinners.
I'd organize these big dinners,
and there's 400, 500, 600
people at these dinners.
I couldn't do it.
I couldn't get their attention.
And Congressman Elijah
Cummings comes up,
and he just leans into the mic.
Shh.
And it quieted the
whole place down.
I said, Congressman,
what is this?
Is this something you've
learned in politics,
something you learned from
your minister, your priest?
He said, it works every
time, works every time.
So Elijah Cummings gave
me that little duty.
Blockchain and
money, we're here.
I know it's a little
bit like eating broccoli
these last couple of
classes, because we went
through cryptography, and
then we moved a little bit
into consensus protocols.
And today, we're going to pick
that up and try to finish up
the design bits of Bitcoin.
I wanted to introduce,
though, one walk-in.
We're going to have
walk-ins from time to time
in this class.
But Patrick Murck,
he's hiding over here
with the cap in the hoodie.
He's got the look
for a lawyer who's
been spending his time around
Bitcoin for seven years.
Now, he's currently affiliated
with Berkman Klein at Harvard.
And I didn't know Patrick
was going to be here,
so I'm calling him out.
He's also special counsel
of the Cooley law firm.
And he has a bunch
of clients who
try to do the right
thing by the law.
But sometimes they
find themselves
dealing with the Securities
and Exchange Commission
or other fine
government institutions.
But Patrick was
also general counsel
to the Bitcoin Foundation.
And for a short while,
you ran it, didn't you,
before it kind of went puff?
PATRICK MURCK: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
But Patrick's the type
of lawyer that wears
a hoodie and a baseball cap.
He's a Bitcoin lawyer.
If you ever need Patrick for
one of your entrepreneurial
efforts, I'm sure Cooley law
firm will like advising you,
too.
AUDIENCE: Do you take bitcoin?
GARY GENSLER: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Does he take bitcoin?
PATRICK MURCK: I have.
[INAUDIBLE] In fact, I've
never bought a bitcoin, ever.
[INAUDIBLE] paid 100% in
bitcoin, so it's all good.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY GENSLER: So
Patrick, when you
get paid 100% in
bitcoin from a client,
how long do you hold it?
PATRICK MURCK: Well,
it depends, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PATRICK MURCK: Often,
in the early days--
not very long,
because I had to pay
for my mortgage and my kid's
daycare and things like that,
and they don't take bitcoin.
So I've sold a lot of
bitcoin over the years.
Something sadly, but
I never bought them.
I just earned them.
GARY GENSLER: Earned them--
so you're like a miner,
except for you're a
lawyer who gets bitcoin.
[LAUGHTER]
PATRICK MURCK: I
mine with my mind.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY GENSLER: The study
questions for today
was, we were going to
turn to that last piece
about transactions and something
called the unspent transaction
output, and script code that
is a computer code that's
used inside of Bitcoin.
We're going to talk a
little bit about the design
features bringing it all
together, and particularly
around the reading, which
was the academic pedigree
of Bitcoin.
Which is also a
reading that Patrick
assigns when he does his study
group at Harvard Law, as well.
And then, yes, all
of you are going
to be able to participate.
And we're going to take a
survey amongst all of you
as to who's Satoshi Nakamoto.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Or would you rather do more
on transactions script?
[LAUGHTER]
All right, we'll do
a little bit of both.
The readings, of course, the
Bitcoin Academic Pedigree,
which we're going to talk
about in the latter part.
And I'll do a
little cold-calling
and get some feedback as to what
you thought from the reading
or if you're still skimming it.
And then there was a
CoinDesk article, just
making sense of it all.
And so as I said, we'll go
through the transactions.
We'll do a little bit of
putting it all together
and the Academic Pedigree.
We'll have a little fun.
You all are going
to have a chance
to tell us who Satoshi Nakamoto
is, or was, or the committee.
So transactions-- you've
seen this graph before.
But transactions, the
format in a transaction
ledger-- not only in Bitcoin,
but really everything--
is somebody on one
side of a transaction
and somebody on another
side of a transaction.
So in Bitcoin, there's an input.
And the input inside of Bitcoin
is an ID of a previous output.
So not only is Bitcoin a series
of blocks of information--
each block that has 1,000 to
2,000 individual transactions--
but in a sense, there's a
separate chain that's going on.
I sometimes think
of a blockchain
as, yes, there's the chain
of big chunks of data,
but there's also a chain
of individual transactions.
Shimon, is that a hand raised
or just scratching your head?
AUDIENCE: I'll be more careful.
GARY GENSLER: No,
that's all right.
Shimon is a faculty member
of the Finance department
here at Sloan.
And some of you might take his
Finance 1 course, I assume.
Somebody in here is, probably.
So the input is
just really the idea
of wherever the output was.
You can think of a
chain of a transaction.
Can anybody tell me where
all transactions come from?
Where's sort of the genesis
of the value, if you
follow a transaction
chain back to its origin?
Hugo.
AUDIENCE: Coinbase.
GARY GENSLER:
Coinbase-- so anybody
want to say what a Coinbase is?
AUDIENCE: It's a generation
of a freshly minted bitcoin.
GARY GENSLER: Right,
so the generation
of a freshly minted bitcoin--
not the way that Patrick Murck
got it when he's selling
his services for the law,
but how a miner gets it,
they get their transactions.
Remember initially, 50 coins
was what happened initially back
in 2009.
Now it's 12 and 1/2 coins.
And in a short couple--
maybe it's about
18 or 20 months,
it goes to 6 and 1/4 coins.
And it keeps splitting half
and half and half, eventually
to no Coinbase.
But every transaction,
in essence,
had to go back all
the way to Coinbase--
some Coinbase, some 50 or 25 or
12 and 1/2 coins being issued.
And then the output--
so a transaction format
is pretty straightforward,
in a sense.
The input is a previous output
and a digital signature,
and then, to whom do
you want to send it.
And it's sent to
Bitcoin addresses.
That's why we spent
just a moment--
we just glossed over what
a Bitcoin address is.
It's sort of a translation
to a public key,
but it's not identical
to a public key.
And of course, you need value.
Value measured in
bitcoins or satoshis,
or if we're on the
Ethereum network,
it would be an ether and
gas, et cetera, et cetera.
On 1,600 different
platforms, it could
be a different native currency.
Lock time, I don't
think lock time
was in any of the readings.
But anybody want to tell
me what a lock time is?
It's relevant to some of
how the technology goes.
Anybody want to take a guess?
Where's Alin?
Not Alin the PhD, but Alin
from the digital currency
initiative.
No?
You're hiding.
You don't want to say
what a lock time is?
AUDIENCE: I thought it's some
sort of protection mechanism
for, I guess, double spending.
GARY GENSLER: It is a protection
mechanism, but not so much
about double spending.
Tom, did I see your hand up?
AUDIENCE: This is a guess.
Is it when the
transaction is hashed?
GARY GENSLER: It's when.
It's about time.
It's when the
transaction can happen.
So right now, it's
2:45 on September 20.
If you put a lock time
in at 2:50 or 2:55,
it couldn't happen until 2:55.
So you can actually
conditional the transaction.
That's all lock time is.
But you can say, it
can't happen until.
You could put tomorrow's date.
AUDIENCE: The
counterparty sets that,
so it's like the
date on a check?
GARY GENSLER: It's a little
different than a date
on a check.
Because one of the things
that gets validated in Bitcoin
is, is that it will not
validate a transaction early.
And if you put October 6
on a handwritten check,
the bank might still take
it, even though they probably
shouldn't.
So it is like the
date on a check,
except it's verified and
validated and so forth.
I'm going to take
Emily and then Shimon.
AUDIENCE: So if you were to set
the lock time in the future,
could that mess up the
blocks in the chain?
What is kind of the
right chain of events
that you're recognizing
if you're choosing to set
a lock time in the future?
I guess the broader question
would be, why would you
set a lock time in the future?
GARY GENSLER: Shimon,
were you answering that?
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
I want to ask you, in the
[INAUDIBLE] question section,
is what purpose does
it serve, right?
AUDIENCE: It's not a really
Turing complete language,
so you're not really trying
to create conditions here.
But this is sort of a condition.
GARY GENSLER: So
it's a condition.
Because at any
point in time, you
might want a
condition of payment.
You might want a condition
of payment on time.
And we're, in a
few slides, going
to talk about the scripting
language, the computer
language that allows
transactions to happen.
Shimon said, was
not Turing complete.
From the readings,
anybody want to tell us
what Turing complete is in
computer science language?
No?
Anybody know who Turing is?
Anybody see Imitation Games.
Anyone know what
the Turing Award is?
It's sort of the Nobel Laureate
for computer scientists.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that the
award when the machine can
actually can pass
as a human being?
GARY GENSLER: Well, that's one
thing associated with Turing.
But the Turing Award
is an annual award,
sort of like a Nobel Laureate,
but for computer scientists.
Turing complete allows
you to do loops inside
of computer programs.
And the script language does
not allow that to happen.
Every function needs to
sort of have some language.
I know Alin looking at
me to see I don't dive.
But to answer Emily's
question, it's just,
there's so many different ways
to condition a transaction.
And Satoshi Nakamoto
thought, well,
let's put it in here, right
in the transaction format,
that you can condition on time.
And then two parties
could do that.
To your question about
whether it could inadvertently
lead to double spending,
it's a very good question.
Can I hold it until we just
do validation for a second?
So this is a unique
identifier for the input.
But it's really uniquely
identifying from a past output.
What's the block number?
Is it from the 250,000th
block or the 300,000th block?
So it takes
literally a block ID.
And then within that block,
which one of its 1,500
transactions might it be?
So you can find any transaction
on an entire blockchain
by knowing the block, and
then within the block, which
transaction.
It's just a data mechanism
on how to store data.
And through this
mechanism, there's
a chain of transactions, as
well as a chain of blocks.
And then the value we
talked about that--
I think there's, if I
did my numbers right,
10 to the 8th satoshis
in every bitcoin.
It's a little hard
because I think
there's 10 to the ninth
gas in every ether.
And that's a coin.
That is what is a coin.
When Satoshi Nakamoto did
this, it wasn't really
a coin, because it was a
question whether anybody
would give value.
And until about 18
months later, when
those two pizzas went for
10,000 bitcoin, what was it?
Or until somebody started
the first exchange,
a crypto exchange,
to exchange that.
So you can also have multiple
inputs and multiple outputs.
And I'm going to use an
example that I just created of,
I want to send some bitcoins
to two different people.
And I need some bitcoins.
So I might grab
three former inputs.
And these are just
Transaction ID 6, Index 3.
Of course, it wouldn't be ID 6.
It might be ID 300,000.
But the point being
is, grab 10 bitcoin,
so I want to find three inputs.
And I needed to send six
bitcoins, let's say, to Amanda.
You like that.
And just because you're
sitting up front, James,
I'm just going to send three.
But I'm not using Amanda's
name and James' name.
I'm using your Bitcoin address--
Amanda's Bitcoin address,
and James' Bitcoin address.
So rather than
being account-based,
like if you have an account at
Bank of America, and you say,
I want to send $10,
I just check to make
sure I have more than $10.
In Bitcoin, I actually have
to fine individual transaction
outputs that add up
to-- in this case,
I want to send nine bitcoin,
six to Amanda, three to James.
Not really, Amanda.
So what's 10 minus 9?
AUDIENCE: 1.
GARY GENSLER: Thank you.
That was really hard.
We are at MIT.
But I might not
send one back to me.
I'm going to send
0.9 back to me.
This is kind of my change.
So a Bitcoin transaction
can either be equal,
the inputs equal the outputs.
I could have sent
one back to me.
But I've decided to
incentivize miners and leave
a little extra, 0.1 bitcoin,
which would be a lot of fee,
actually.
That would be about,
what, $640 or so?
I probably wouldn't do that.
I would probably leave for a fee
10 or 20 or 100 satoshi maybe.
I don't know what the
current market is.
But this is a transaction.
Multiple inputs, multiple
outputs, but you always
have to send back to yourself.
What happens to these inputs
if this transaction actually
happens?
They go away.
The actual inputs disappear
once they go through this.
And so inputs always
have to equal outputs.
When a transaction is validated,
one of the validation methods
is to make sure that the lock
time has actually happened,
that you've passed
the lock time.
Another validation point is
that inputs are greater than
or equal to outputs.
If outputs are
greater than inputs,
the transaction will
not be validated.
The digital signatures
have to be validated,
going just back to
the prior slide.
That digital signature has
to be validated, as well.
And that, this previous ID
and index actually exists.
And this is getting to
your question Emily.
It still exists.
But these inputs,
once you've used them,
they no longer exist
in the database.
They're kind of in the past.
So that's the transactions.
That's the core.
I know it's like
eating broccoli,
but it's an important part of
all of blockchain technology.
The Coinbase transaction
we've already talked about,
so I'll slide over this quickly.
But it's a reward for
solving the puzzle.
In the case of Bitcoin, it's
solving the proof of work.
Tom.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, can we go
back to the miner incentive.
It's the 0.1 or 1 satoshis.
And how is that different
than the cost of trust
when you use a financial
institution as the [INAUDIBLE]??
GARY GENSLER: So Tom's question
is, the miners' economics.
Of course, they get
their 12 and 1/2 bitcoin,
and they might get
some transaction fees.
Tom's question's the other side.
Why is that any
different than paying
some central intermediary?
Anybody want to try doing this?
I could cold-call, but
does anybody want to--
this is an economics
question about markets.
AUDIENCE: I would say
that the person that
is sending the transaction
has the ability
to choose how much it will
pay for that transaction.
And in the bank, it's
regulated, and you pay.
Maybe that's one
of the differences.
GARY GENSLER: All
right, so one difference
is that the bank is setting,
generally, a fixed fee
schedule, and this is
a decentralized market
mechanism for setting fees.
Sean.
AUDIENCE: The fee for
intermediaries a lot higher
compared to Bitcoin,
the transaction fees.
GARY GENSLER: So
Sean's second point
is that, currently-- this might
not be true in the future.
But currently,
central intermediaries
are able to charge higher fees
than in this decentralized
system.
Alin?
AUDIENCE: I think that,
conceptually, it's
not different from a
centralized intermediary.
It's just, the
functions are the same.
The amounts, maybe
the amount that I pay,
the amount of the
fees are different,
but the concepts are the same.
GARY GENSLER: All right, so
Alin is basically saying,
well, maybe it's
not so different.
I mean, though it might be
floating rather than fixed,
it might be currently
lower rather than higher,
but you're saying,
fundamentally, it's
about the same.
One minute, Shimon,
let me just--
because you're faculty.
You're going to actually
tell us the answer.
AUDIENCE: Question--
is this mandatory?
GARY GENSLER: Very good
question-- it's not mandatory.
AUDIENCE: So that could create
a big misalignment of interest.
GARY GENSLER: So
it's not mandatory.
Fees are market-based.
And at times, like
last December,
they were really high.
And now they're
quite low, partly
because the Bitcoin network is
not humming at full capacity.
It can readily fit 1,000 to
2,000 transactions a block.
And it's not like
there's a jamming
to get 10,000 and 20,000
transactions into a block,
as there was last December.
I'm sorry, Shimon.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's very different,
in the sense that
you're basically
inflating the fee in most
[INAUDIBLE] inflation.
So even if when
you don't transact,
you're paying implicitly for
other people's transactions,
and that's going to
change over time.
So that's actually kind
of a clever mechanism
of how, structurally,
these are going
to shift over time
in the network,
as it hopefully matures.
GARY GENSLER: Why don't
we take one more here--
Alexis.
AUDIENCE: That's like when
you have [INAUDIBLE] they're
going to keep the money.
And they could use it for
making [INAUDIBLE] or whatever.
So they make money on a spread.
Whereas here, for
the case of Bitcoin,
the money's going to
stay in the system,
and it's going to flow
to another miner, who
is going to use it for
another transaction.
It will stay within the
same network, I would say,
rather than just going
to another destination.
GARY GENSLER: I hear you.
But it might actually leave
the network to lawyers,
like Patrick.
Or it might leave the network
if you use it at Starbucks,
if Starbucks would accept it.
So I'm challenging
your thought, but you
can challenge mine back.
Why don't we close out with
Eric, and then just move on.
AUDIENCE: The difference
might be in the perspective.
From the person that's
originated a transaction,
it's basically the same thing.
But if you think
about it as a system,
there's no single entity
gathering all the money
from transactions.
You have a network, a
[INAUDIBLE] network,
of [INAUDIBLE] that
are getting that.
And besides, once we get
out past the 21 million
bitcoin generation cap,
then all the systems
must be using
[INAUDIBLE] in some way.
And transaction fees
would be [INAUDIBLE]..
GARY GENSLER: So Eric raises
two points that I'll--
there are other points, but
two that I want to repeat.
One is, this is more
decentralized possibly today
than the current commercial
banking system, for instance,
for transaction processing,
or the transaction processing
that Visa and First
Data do, which we'll
study when we get to payments.
So it's possibly
more decentralized.
I think you said it
was more decentralized,
but I'm putting the
word possibly in there.
And two is that, at
least in bitcoin's case,
there's two revenue sources
for providing the services.
The miners do it for the
Coinbase transactions, 12
and 1/2 bitcoin per block,
approximately $80,000 US
per block currently.
But also, there's
this little incentive
of fees, which, over time, will
have to grow as you go down.
If it's only going to be
one bitcoin per transaction,
and then ultimately almost
0 bitcoin for transaction,
there will have to be more
satoshis in the fee side.
And some alternative coins--
not Bitcoin-- are
more modeled on fees,
and some coins are more
modeled on mining rewards.
The economics--
Satoshi Nakamoto,
whomever he or she was,
or were, if it's a group,
had to think through
a bunch of economics.
They've survived for 10 years.
It doesn't mean that's the
best set of microeconomics
for a blockchain system.
Tom, you look really skeptical.
AUDIENCE: I'm skeptical.
But maybe this
would be the moment
where I take my 12-hour dive.
GARY GENSLER: That's right.
So you're about ready
for your rabbit dive?
Maybe.
AUDIENCE: Maybe.
GARY GENSLER: So the
Coinbase transaction
we've talked a lot about.
The reward, at least in Bitcoin,
halves every 210,000 blocks.
A very important thing
that Nakamoto put in
is, you couldn't use your
Coinbase reward for 100 blocks.
So it was sort of stale
or frozen for 100 blocks.
I can think of two
reasons, but maybe you all
would think of another reason.
Anybody want to give it a shot
as to why you might do it?
Xiaojian
AUDIENCE: Maybe
you mine the block,
and you're trying to mine
a block that shouldn't be--
or it's not legal.
You spend the money right
away so you can get--
GARY GENSLER: This is
the principal reason
that's talked about, not
only in the literature,
but in the early blog post,
was, well, how many blocks does
the chain have to go
before everybody really
thinks it's consensus?
You could have said 5, 10, 20.
Satoshi picked 100
blocks, saying,
that, hopefully,
is pretty settled,
or about 1,000 minutes.
James.
AUDIENCE: If you mine,
and then you can spend,
couldn't you just
perpetually create blocks
and then pay yourself and
create more and earn more
and then keep building
up [INAUDIBLE]??
GARY GENSLER: So
James is asking,
could you just kind
of game the system
and keep mining and spending
and mining and spending?
AUDIENCE: Then your
rewards go down.
GARY GENSLER: Sorry, Aviva?
AUDIENCE: Then your
awards go down over time.
GARY GENSLER: Well, that
takes 200,000 blocks.
AUDIENCE: But if there
are many of you doing that
at the same time, then
you accelerate the--
GARY GENSLER: So in some ways,
that's what miners are doing.
But they have to
wait 100 blocks.
And so that was what Satoshi
was trying to get at.
If you have to wait 100 blocks,
it's probably now the consensus
chain.
It's probably been so
validated, unless we
got into the problem--
Patrick, you weren't here.
But some of the students
raised the question, well,
what if one country
as large as China
walled off their whole
network, and just China
went one way and the rest
of the world went another?
The theory of the case is
that, within 100 blocks
or 1,000 minutes, somehow
that would be discovered.
But if it weren't, you might
have a little bit of what
James is raising as a question.
But that's at least
the theory of the case.
It's always recorded as the
first transaction in the Merkle
Tree.
Highly technical
point, but it has
to roll up into that darn
thing we were talking about,
the data compression
at the Merkle Tree.
And here's a little fun fact.
You can add 100 bytes of
arbitrary data in a Coinbase.
You might say, why
does he raise this?
Well, because it's
just a fun little place
that some people express their
creative wit, artistic stuff,
send secret messages
to each other,
that, buried in the
Coinbase transactions,
there is a whole forensics
of fun little things
that sometimes miners
put in to the Coinbase,
for those of you
who are artistic.
The very first genesis
block had this sentence.
"The Times, January 3,
2009, Chancellor on brink
of second bailout for banks."
That was a headline out
of the Financial Times
that says Satoshi Nakamoto put
in the first block of Coinbase.
It's just a little fun place.
There's a playfulness that goes
on amongst miners, sometimes
talking to each other.
Did you ever get a message?
Did anybody send you--
PATRICK MURCK: Not
that I'm aware of.
I know what you're
talking about.
There's one miner that likes
to put Catholic catechisms in.
GARY GENSLER: That has put
in the whole catechism?
PATRICK MURCK: In every block,
there's a little catechism
that he puts in.
It's a Allegis mining pool.
It's a small one.
So there you go.
GARY GENSLER: There you go.
And do they pay you
in bitcoin, too?
PATRICK MURCK: No,
they're not a client.
GARY GENSLER: OK.
So it all rolls into a database
called the unspent transaction
output.
These are the
unspent transactions.
If it's been spent,
it's kind of burned.
And bitcoin transactions
that haven't been spent
fall into this.
And you can use it.
It's created because it
speeds up the whole system.
Instead of going back and
looking for all these things,
there's actually a
database that has
all the unspent transactions.
I include in here
what I find as a sort
of interesting
revelation or irony.
When Satoshi built Bitcoin,
and for the 16 versions
that have come since
over the 10 years,
all the developers, the
Bitcoin core developers,
have kept the unspent
transaction output,
not on a blockchain
specifically, but in a database
called a LevelDB database.
So those of you who are closer
to computer science than I
could say all the pros and
cons of a LevelDB database.
But I'm just
observing that, even
within the most used first
central database for blockchain
called Bitcoin, they chose
to use not a blockchain,
but, in essence, a more
standard database to keep
the unspent transaction output.
Now, in a sense, it's all part
of this blockchain solution.
I'm just saying,
it's one database
within the blockchain
world that's
actually not a blockchain.
It's just sort of an
interesting irony.
But it also sort of
says, economically
and technologically,
Satoshi was trying
to create a money system.
He wasn't trying
to use blockchain
for every bit of data.
So this is the actual size of
the unspent transaction output.
If you can't see, there's--
I think it's about
50 to 60 million.
It was higher.
There was about 60
million unspent.
It's not 60 million
bitcoins, because there's
about 17 million bitcoin.
So you could average it out.
You could say, well,
each transaction
has less than 1 bitcoin.
Well actually, there's been
surveys and studies showing
that about half of these
54 million transactions are
so small that they go by the
term of-- they're called dust.
That there's so few
satoshi that it's not
even worth the fees
to try to redeem them.
They only add up to less
than a half a percent
of all the outstanding
bitcoin, but they're just dust.
So maybe out of these 54 million
unspent transaction outputs,
half of them will never
be used, because it's not
economically worthwhile.
It's like the pennies in
the top dresser drawer
that you all might not spend.
There's this similar thing here.
Hugo.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I guess I
have a question about that.
It might not be
feasible now, but maybe
with layers on top of
bitcoin that people can
do these micro-transactions.
Because like, our pennies
might be worth a lot
of money, [INAUDIBLE].
GARY GENSLER: So
Hugo is raising that,
just like the pennies in
your top dresser drawer
might be worth
something one day,
what I'm referencing as
Bitcoin dust, about half
of these unspent transaction
outputs, a satoshi here,
10 satoshi there, might
one day be worth something.
Good point.
It's just like the pennies in
your top dresser drawer though.
Have you lost them
in the meantime?
They might be worth something.
But in the meantime, have
you lost the private key
to those little satoshis?
I put on here three
moments of time
just to give you the
sense of the actual number
of transactions
that have happened.
There's been 342 million
transactions on the Bitcoin
network to date, or
as of a day or two ago
when I put the slides together.
So of the 340
million transactions,
only about 54 million
are still outstanding.
The other 290 million have
been spent, if you wish.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So then where are
these outstanding transactions
stored?
Are they still being included
in the blocks themselves,
where you add them
to the [INAUDIBLE]??
GARY GENSLER: Which outstanding
transactions, the 54 million
that are still available?
The 54 million all reside in
a database within the Bitcoin
software called the unspent
transaction output, UTXO.
And UTXO-- these aren't
letters I'm making up--
that's a database, 54
million transactions.
Separately, they are actually
in the blockchain itself.
So all 340 million transactions
that have ever happened
are in the blockchain.
But to make it easier for
the software, the 54 million
that have never been spent
reside in a software.
Does that answer the question?
Work with me.
AUDIENCE: So it's a
distributed database
amongst all the different nodes.
GARY GENSLER: Correct.
All 10,000 of the nodes
can have the full UTXO set.
Some wallet providers
have the full UTXO set,
but they don't have to.
Somewhat lightweight nodes
usually don't, but can.
But a lightweight
node would never
want to have all 340 million
and the full blockchain.
So in essence, they're
in multiple places,
because they're in the full
blockchain, 10,000 nodes.
And they're also in the UTXO,
not only on the 10,000 nodes,
but occasionally elsewhere.
Alin.
AUDIENCE: So I heard you say
the word spent transaction,
which is a bit misleading.
Because a transaction can
be spent and not spent.
Because, for example, you
would have two outputs.
One output is spent by
a future transaction,
and the other
output is not spent.
So it's a bit misleading
to say spent transaction,
because that only happens when
the transaction has only one
output and that output is spent.
GARY GENSLER: Well,
I'm using it lightly.
I'm saying that, of the 340
million transactions that
have happened, 290--
AUDIENCE: Have an
output that is spent,
or what are you saying exactly?
Because transactions
have multiple outputs.
They might have n, and
maybe k of them are spent.
So the other
outputs are unspent.
GARY GENSLER: I'm saying
there's 340 million--
if I did my data search
correctly-- and I'm fallible,
so I might not have.
But if I did my data
source correctly,
there was 340 million
previous outputs.
290 million of them are gone.
AUDIENCE: OK, so then you
should say transaction outputs,
because those are different
than transactions.
GARY GENSLER: Yes.
Except for it was
easier to put TXS.
But yes, Alin's clarification
is, I believe, accurate.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
so people can understand
that there is a difference
between a transaction
and a transaction output.
GARY GENSLER: In essence,
what Alin's saying is,
there's currently 54
million transaction outputs
in the UTXO, which
also says outputs.
There had been, in the past,
another 290 million outputs
that have already been spent.
Are we together?
So there's a scripting language.
There's a little bit
of computer code.
I said there was no prerequisite
to take any computer
science before you were here.
And my own computer
programming is so old,
because when I was programming,
it was in Fortran and APL.
And you can look that up.
It's kind of like
around with cuneiform
and you know the Rosetta Stone.
But Satoshi Nakamoto
decided to put a little bit
of computer programming inside.
And I'm not going to
get the count right,
but there's several hundred,
but not several thousand,
little operations
and codes that you
can use in the Bitcoin script.
It's not Turing
complete, which means
you can't do a lot of the
things that you can do in all
the rest of computer science.
But it's more secure.
In essence, it has
fewer attack vectors.
It's harder to bring
down a little bit.
It's a programming
code, as I said.
For those interested,
it's called stack-based,
where you sort of move the
code over one at a time
as it's being performed.
And it gives some flexibility.
And back to Emily's question
about why there was lock time,
or Shimon's, scripting code
allows for some conditionality,
that it appears that
Nakamoto was trying
to give some
ability to condition
a transaction on events, but
not so much conditionality, so
much flexibility, that he
needed a Turing complete.
So he kind of, I'm going to
say, chose a midway place.
I believe, you could
have created Bitcoin
and say there was no
scripting language.
It was just going to be a
straight instruction, moving
this input to another output.
Created a little bit of
computer code, but not a lot.
That's what I think of the
economics and the marketplace
for this.
And next Tuesday when we
talk about smart contracts--
and I promise you,
there's a reason
for the craziness of
my talking about Turing
complete and scripting code.
Because next Tuesday, we'll be
talking about smart contracts
where they're much
more flexible.
And so this is sort
of the foundational--
and you don't need
to know anything
more about computer
science than you want,
unless you go with Tom
down that rabbit hole
and spend more time reading.
So there's four different types
of, I call them script types.
They're not actual script
words, but you will read
about these from time to time.
And I just wanted
to cover these four.
The UTXO, remember, is about
54 million transactions.
And there's been a
nice academic paper
that I didn't assign that
was written earlier this year
that investigated
the whole 54 million,
all of the unspent transactions.
And this is how it broke down.
81% are transactions that send
to a hash of a Bitcoin address.
Eight, nine years ago
when Satoshi created this,
that was not the most
popular instruction.
But it's basically
sending an output
to the hash, the compression,
the commitment of a Bitcoin
address.
We're now up to 18%.
This didn't exist three
and four years ago, really.
But 18% go to a
conditional script.
It's a hash of a
So somebody saying, Emily,
it's not even about time.
It's like, you can
only get it when
all these other instructions
that are in the scripting
language happen.
And I'm going to hide the
conditions in a hash of it.
And then only 0.1% goes
the way that he first
envisioned nine years ago,
directly to a Bitcoin address.
So it's either to a hash
of a Bitcoin address,
a hash of a conditional script,
and a little less than 1% now
go to multiple signatures.
Meaning, you need two out of
three or three out of five.
Or believe it or not,
this academic paper
shows that some say 0 out of 1.
Now, it's hard to believe that
somebody mistakenly programmed
something to go to 0 signatures,
but apparently somebody did.
So I just wanted to
give you a sense there's
some flexibility in the computer
code, not a lot of flexibility,
but just enough that you can do
things that are really helpful.
And they're going to solve a
lot of challenges for Bitcoin.
Hugo mentioned layer 2.
We're going to be talking about
layer 2 later in the semester,
where there's a whole way to put
technology on top of Bitcoin.
And it's because the
scripting language is there
that you can do that.
Any questions on script?
I know I'm trying to cover
a big, weighty topic in 120
seconds or less.
No?
So just back to the whole--
this is just a review.
What have we've talked about?
There's that little
graphic again.
It's just a bunch of blocks.
That's what a blockchain is.
Though today, we realize
that underneath the blocks,
we have another chain.
I often think of two chains--
the chains of blocks.
In Bitcoin, there's about
a half a million blocks.
But underneath that, there's
all the transactions that
are, in fact, chained, as well.
54 million of those outputs
have not yet been spent
and 290 million outputs
have been spent.
But underneath about a
half a million blocks,
there's been 340 million
outputs, so to speak.
It creates a database.
Bitcoin is a
transaction database.
Next Tuesday, we'll talk about
an account-based database
in Ethereum.
But it could be a ledger
which is transactions
or a ledger which is balances.
Satoshi Nakamoto decided
to do transactions here.
In some ways, I believe it's
because it was fewer attack
vectors.
Probably a little
bit more secure,
but I'm not entirely sure.
And until you solve the riddle
as to who Satoshi Nakamoto is,
we won't know the answer.
Of
Course, hash functions
we talked about,
and digital signatures,
and a consensus protocol.
So I like to think of
it in three buckets,
whether it's for a
dinner party conversation
or digging into three lectures.
It's the cryptography itself.
We did that last Thursday.
And if you have to
remember anything,
it's only two
cryptographic primitives--
hash functions and
digital signatures.
How many people think
they kind of roughly have
what a hash function is?
All right, so I
lost half of you.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, is there anything
I can do for Lauren's table?
I didn't see a
single hand go up.
Are you reading
your Facebook page
or are you listening
to the class?
You've got your computer open.
What's your name.
AUDIENCE: Matthew.
GARY GENSLER: Matthew.
All right, that might
have been that you
weren't listening to the class.
Thank you.
How can I help in what
a hash function is?
My promise is to
bring everybody along.
Nobody at your table
said you even roughly got
what a hash function is.
I'm not trying to
embarrass anybody.
I'm trying to work this through.
Nicholas, so give me a baseline.
Did you read any
of the readings?
Maybe not.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I have, yes.
GARY GENSLER: You have, OK.
Hash functions came
along decades ago
to help facilitate
database management.
Sometimes it's
called a registry.
It's taking a lot of data
and shrinking it down,
compressing it, shrinking it,
to maybe a series of numbers.
I think of it sometimes as
a zip code for information.
Down in Baltimore,
Maryland, I'm in 2120--
well, I grew up in 21208.
It was my parent's zip code.
I won't say my current.
We're being videoed.
[LAUGHTER]
And so I think of it a
little bit like that.
So a hash function that has
nothing to do with bitcoin
came along to take a bunch of
data and create a registry.
But through that, it also
became a way to do a commitment.
Yes, your first name?
AUDIENCE: Dana.
GARY GENSLER: Dana?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, Dana.
What goes into the hash function
and comes out as a hash,
that's what I don't understand.
GARY GENSLER: So what goes
in is any set of data.
Today, that could
be an entire movie.
It could be a picture of
everybody in this room.
Initially, it was mostly
alphanumeric data.
But because, in
computer technology,
all data can be broken down
to a series of registries
of 0's or 1's--
computers started with--
literally the first one
started with registries that
were either turned on or off.
If they were on, call that a 1.
If it was off, call it a 0.
I'm not sure which way it goes.
I keep looking at Alin.
And so all data can
then be brought down
to a series of 0's and 1.
And if you put four 0's and 1's
in front of each other, 2 times
2 times 2 times 2, 2 to the
fourth is 16, all of a sudden,
you see if you keep
going 2 to something,
you can get a lot of data.
So sit back to
answer your question
Dana, when we talked last
week about The New York Times
crossword puzzle--
The New York Times
may, if they wish,
take the solution of their
crossword puzzle and hash it.
And then Stephanie?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GARY GENSLER: Stephanie likes
to do The New York Times
crossword puzzle.
And she wants to know if she
properly completed The New York
Times crossword puzzle.
The New York Times could
say to her cell phone,
we're not going to really
give you the answer,
but we'll give you the
hash of the answer.
And then when she's finished
and she pushes a button,
her application could say
whether her answer properly
hashes to theirs.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: Please.
We're trying to
learn here together.
AUDIENCE: In the
case of a blockchain,
it's whatever dated you
loaded to the blockchain,
and then in Bitcoin, it's
just the transactions.
Is that right?
GARY GENSLER: So in
Bitcoin and blockchain,
they use hash functions
in several big ways.
Everything you said was
correct, except for the one
thing when you said, it's just.
Because they actually use
hash functions in the middle
of the proof of work.
Because the hash
pointer points--
block 3 points to block
2 and there's hashing.
They use the hash function to
compress a bunch of data, what
I call the Merkle
Tree, but it's taking
1,500 or 2,000 transactions
and squeezing it into one hash.
So they're hashing all
of these things up.
It uses hash functions in the
midst of the Bitcoin address.
So the hash function
is like electricity
in the middle of it, almost.
It's probably used
six or eight places,
and some I don't, in
any way, know myself
or need to understand.
Nicolas, how are we doing?
Did we get a little closer?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GARY GENSLER: Lauren, did
we get a little closer?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GARY GENSLER: Matt?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
GARY GENSLER: You're there.
AUDIENCE: I'm not there
yet, but I'm closer.
GARY GENSLER: Stop by.
Send me an email.
It's gensler@mit.edu.
I'm here like four days a week.
Ben.
AUDIENCE: So I think
the time that I really
understood hash
functions was when
I saw someone do a live demo.
It's a website called
[INAUDIBLE] Brain Wallet.
But you type in text,
and in real time,
it converts it into a hash.
So
GARY GENSLER: Say the
website again, Ben.
AUDIENCE: It's brainwallet.io.
GARY GENSLER: Brainwallet.io--
a recommendation.
AUDIENCE: You can also just
Google Brain Wallet blockchain.
And you can type in text,
and you see in real time
it converts it into
a Bitcoin address.
If you change one letter, or
make one in uppercase or one
in lower case, it
changes in real time.
And it's just, you put any
text in, you put a password in,
and it turns it into
a blockchain address.
And that's all a hash is.
It translates text into a hash.
GARY GENSLER: Or a whole movie.
We talked about the
network consensus,
how to actually agree on
the state of information
with no centralized authority.
You don't have a central
bank or a commercial bank
or a Facebook or a
parental unit, if you wish.
It's all of us out
there on the playground
figuring it out
together somehow.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I
have a quesiton here.
For the proof of
work, my question
is, for example, I
make a transaction,
does it mean I have to wait for
10 minutes for the transaction
to be completed?
Or for example, when we do
Venmo, it's like instantaneous.
I can immediately
get the results.
GARY GENSLER: Anton's
question is, does it
mean I have to wait 10 minutes?
Venmo and so many other payment
practices can go more quickly.
The answer to you is, yes.
And that is one of the
commercial challenges
to blockchain as we
know it in Bitcoin.
There are certain approaches
to that, layering in technology
on top of, they call it
layer 2 or lightning network.
We're not going to dive
into lightning network.
But everybody should hold
onto Anton's question.
It's the right question,
that if all of you
bring your critical reasoning
to this class about markets
and about commercial realities,
a little bit about the law
and a little bit
about technology.
Because that's what
we're trying to do.
It's like, oh, well
does this really matter?
Will it work?
Hugo.
AUDIENCE: So just a point
of contention here--
GARY GENSLER: Contention?
AUDIENCE: A little bit.
GARY GENSLER: Oh, very good.
I like that.
AUDIENCE: So if
you know the person
that you're transacting with,
you can accept the transaction
with 0 confirmations.
As long as it gets
into the mem pool
and has a reasonable
fee attached to it,
then it will eventually
get included on a block,
and that's probably good
enough for most people.
GARY GENSLER: So what
Hugo is saying is,
another approach is to
take counterparty risk,
that Anton's--
back to Anton's
question-- does it
mean you have to
wait 10 minutes?
The actual technical
answer to that
is, no, you don't have to wait
10 minutes, unless you want
final settlement,
if you want finality
with no counterparty
risk, no commercial risk.
Hugo is saying, well,
if I'm willing to take
some economic or commercial
counterparty risk, which is,
in finance, you take
it all the time,
then maybe I can do it
in less than 10 minutes.
And in fact, even
Starbucks, when
Starbucks accepts your
credit card swipe,
they're taking a little
bit of counterparty risk
from the payment processing
company First Data.
I don't mean to say that
it might not be also
from Visa and the banks.
But I'll just say
the payment system
has some counterparty risk.
Because final settlement
in our payment
system doesn't happen
within seconds.
So the actual answer--
thank you, Hugo.
Clean me up again.
You should do this all the time.
Everybody should clean me up.
It's that final
settlement can happen.
And so you have to
find other solutions,
whether it's some
commercial arrangement
with counterparty risk or
other technical commercial
arrangements.
Shimon?
AUDIENCE: Well, I'll
make a counterargument,
which is that, 10 minutes is
not final settlement, right?
Because it could be forking.
So it's basically
the probability
of the finality
goes up with time,
which is associated with how
many blocks are attached to
[INAUDIBLE].
GARY GENSLER: So Shimon's point
is that, even in 10 minutes,
your probability of
finality is not complete.
Because the block
might not be the block
that's included in
the longest chain.
And many people
have said, you maybe
should wait three
blocks or six blocks.
I think the longest--
I'm going to use
the term loosely--
orphaned chain has
been five blocks long.
And in Bitcoin, what's
the longest orphan?
AUDIENCE: It was
an accidental fork.
It was 20 or more blocks.
Due to some crazy things
that miners were doing,
they accidentally
forked a blockchain.
AUDIENCE: OK, and
what year was that?
AUDIENCE: So look
up March 2013 fork.
And there's another fork
after that, in 2015 maybe.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah, somebody's
been down the rabbit hole.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, there's some
still probabilistic risk.
Aviva, and then we'll move on.
AUDIENCE: What's a fork.
GARY GENSLER: So I
don't have the chart up.
But if you remember,
there was the slide
that showed the longest block.
It was in black.
And it had little purple blocks.
That's a fork.
There's some forks that end up
being that both chains continue
for a long time.
They're called hard forks.
And there is something called--
Bitcoin and Bitcoin Cash
have come out of that.
Most, the way that Alin was
using it, are discarded.
I'm sorry, behind you,
remind me of your first name?
AUDIENCE: Erin.
I don't know.
Let me know if it's
not the right time
to ask this question.
But I'm getting a bit confused
between the most important
things we now need to
know, and the differences
between the technology of
mining Bitcoins versus just
transacting on the blockchain.
What are the major
differences we need to know?
GARY GENSLER: Very
good question, Erin.
Erin's question of, what do
I need to know about mining,
what do I need to know
about transaction,
is it one and the same?
I apologize.
They overlap, but
they're not the same.
So think of a Venn diagram.
But it's a very good question.
The essence of mining is
creating an incentive structure
where there is no
central authority
to validate and put a new
set of transactions or data--
I'm going to say broadly, data--
into the ledger, into the
accepted state of what
reality is.
So mining helps with that.
That's that whole process.
In essence, who gets to
decide the next block of data?
Transactions are included in the
data, but it's not identical.
Mining is really critical, but
it's not the only component.
In terms of
transactions, then you
have to actually think
of, well, there's
this other thing going on.
Well, there's been 340 million
of these in the Bitcoin network
so far.
And has it been used already?
Has it been spent?
Does it have an appropriate
digital signature?
If there's a time lock on
it, is there a condition?
Might there even be this
little bit of scripting code
that puts other
conditions, like there
has to be multiple signatures?
Has it been double spent?
It was a very good question.
They overlap a lot.
One thing you can
just remember is,
mining is about that there's
been a half a million blocks.
Transactions, there's
been 340 million.
So there must be
something else going on
in all those transactions.
Does that help a bit?
Kelly?
AUDIENCE: Since we're
talking about all
the technical features
and how they overlap,
one of the questions was,
what part of blockchain
is novel to Satoshi?
Is the novelty in
bringing it all together,
or is it one specific thing?
Because the paper
talked about the ledger
and creating the
incentive, and then
sort of solving the whole
Byzantine Generals Problem.
But I don't really understand.
Was there a specific
thing that unlocked the--
GARY GENSLER: So
Kelly's question,
which is the heart of the
study questions is, what makes
the whole Satoshi paper novel?
Is it just bringing
it all together,
or is there something more?
I'll give you a hint.
I think there's one other--
I think that the genius can
be just in bringing together
things.
That in itself can
be sheer genius.
AUDIENCE: There's also
the part that, creating
the value in the currency.
But I don't know if that's--
GARY GENSLER: Right, so
creating an incentive structure
within there.
Others?
Derek.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
have a question.
GARY GENSLER: Question, or
answer to Kelly's question?
AUDIENCE: No, I had a question.
GARY GENSLER: All right, I'm
going to hold your question,
Derek, just for a second.
Who's going to help
me with-- because it's
central to the study questions.
AUDIENCE: Just
another thing to add--
the proof of work that
Satoshi did on the consensus
to [INAUDIBLE] it's also novel.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
But novel, though,
didn't Adam Back
already do some
of it in hashcash.
So its application was novel.
I come out where I think
the genius is bringing it
all together, and using
Adam Back's proof of work
in a way that really
addressed double spend.
Adam Back was not dealing
with a double spend issue.
He had different challenges.
It was about email spam.
Frankly, it didn't
even work with email.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] we
weren't counting [INAUDIBLE]
work as a completely
novel thing,
his article discussed how
it was already published.
So I guess it's the application.
GARY GENSLER: It's the
application specifically
to the double spend.
Now, Patrick Murck,
would you answer it then?
This is somebody who ran
the Bitcoin Foundation,
but he's a lawyer, you know?
PATRICK MURCK: I think
that's absolutely right.
So usually-- and I think they
address it in that particular
paper--
when somebody says,
what was a thing
that was different about
Bitcoin from everything else,
the answer is Nakamoto
Consensus, right?
And Nakamoto Consensus,
being the incentive structure
pulling everything together
and aligning everybody
to actually create
trusted signing parties
for this database, without
having to actually trust
or identify those parties.
And that's something that
really hadn't existed before.
And so that's really novel.
That's sort of the
breakthrough that I
think you can attribute to
that particular white paper.
I also use this as a way
to give a clean definition
of blockchain, which is a
badly abused term, as I'm
sure you'll discover through
the rest of this class.
It's saying, to
me, a blockchain is
something that is born
from Nakamoto Consensus.
Blockchains, as they
discuss in that paper,
have existed for decades.
That's not even a
novel data structure.
But using that to form Nakamoto
Con-- that's the thing.
It always sort of
comes back to that.
Anyways, maybe a longer
elaboration than you wanted.
GARY GENSLER: Good,
there we have it.
You now know that you're in a
class that has guest speakers.
I do want to say on the guest
speaker point-- and Derek,
I cognizant that
you have a question,
but we have 12 minutes or so.
Next Tuesday, Larry
Lessig, who sometimes
floats into this class,
has agreed to guest lecture
with me.
And so we're going to
co-do smart contracts.
And let me just say a
little bit about Larry.
You sort of see him here.
He bicycles over from Harvard.
He's a constitutional
scholar that's
a remarkable
constitutional scholar.
And even though he came to be
a full professor at Harvard,
they stole him away
from Stanford actually,
where he was a full
professor, too, readily.
But he's extensively written.
Anybody in here a West Wing
fan, the television series
West Wing?
He is the only--
do you know that Larry
Lessig was in West Wing?
AUDIENCE: No.
GARY GENSLER: Now you do.
Well, Larry was.
And Christopher Lloyd played
Larry Lessig in one episode.
But you'll go back and
you'll find the episode.
And Larry has a funny
story about watching
the filming of it.
But Larry is a constitutional
scholar over at Harvard.
He clerked for Justice
Scalia on the Supreme Court.
He clerked for Posner
over in Chicago.
He knows a lot about contracts.
And so I asked him if he'd
help teach smart contracts
next Tuesday.
So Larry's going to-- we're
going to Mutt and Jeff it up
here next Tuesday.
Watch out, Patrick.
You might be up here one day.
This is not a class
that we're going to have
a lot of guest lecturers.
Later in this
semester, I hope, we're
still in confirming
Jeff Sprecher, who's
the chief executive officer
of Intercontinental Exchange,
runs the New York
Stock Exchange.
Jeff is probably joining us
on, I think it's November 15.
But I really want to stay
to the content and so forth.
Derek, what's your question?
AUDIENCE: I can follow
up with you on that.
GARY GENSLER: OK, follow up.
All right, and then we just
did transactions today.
Remember, the hash function
is The New York Times.
We're in a little better
place with Lauren's table now.
All right, good, good.
My goal is not to
embarrass anybody
when I ask these questions.
My goal is that we all
come along on this journey,
that we somehow have some basis.
Because it does relate
to understanding
the commercial reality
and the economics.
We talked about the time
stamping and the blocks,
the Merkle Trees, which is not a
deep part of it, and of course,
digital signatures.
Part of the reason I
replay this each time
is because, in
politics, I, of course,
learned that repetition is
a really important thing.
[LAUGHTER]
But I also think it's
true in academic settings.
And then Bitcoin addresses,
and that's just a cleanup,
that it's not an
identical to a public.
And then the proof of work,
and back to the questions.
Nakamoto Consensus
is, yes, all of this
and an incentive structure,
but it's this proof of work.
And to Erin's
question, proof of work
is a little bit different
than the transactions
that we talked about, but
there's a lot of overlap.
And then it creates
the native currency.
And I've corrected this
slide to 2140, of course.
The network is
really critical, too,
and that there's all
these different actors
on a network, 10,000 nodes
and this many light nodes
and the miners and the
mining pool operators.
And they all have their
separate economics.
And so if anybody wants to
come and get office hours,
talk about those economics,
please come on in.
If there's nothing you
remember from the reading,
I've now read this
paper probably six times
to kind of slowly get
it through my head.
But every time I
read the Clark paper,
I go, wow, that really helps me.
Because it's not like
Satoshi Nakamoto just flipped
his fingers and there it--
it was on the backs of
a lot of cryptography,
a lot of technology earlier.
But this is the
chart I turn back to,
and it's sometimes helps me.
Ah, there's time-stamping,
there's digital cache,
there's proof of work,
and how these things.
Maybe 10 years from
now, they'll look back
and Nakamoto's stuff
will just be built upon.
That's the central question.
That's what some
of our colleagues
are doing over at the
Digital Currency Initiative
or over at the
Computer Sciences Lab.
They're saying, can
they build upon this
and take it to another level?
Right now-- and you'll see
throughout the semester--
there's not a lot of
full scale applications
of this technology.
But it might just be in
a whole line of this.
Yes, and I can't remember
your first name, Aviva?
AUDIENCE: I'm Aviva.
And that is the
other Indian woman.
GARY GENSLER: That's
the other Aviva.
AUDIENCE: That's the
other Indian woman.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah,
yeah, it's important.
Out of 100 people, we can
have two Avivas, you know?
We could even have two
Aviva's if there's two.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
name's Priya.
AUDIENCE: I'm Priya.
GARY GENSLER: Pria--
oh, I'm sorry.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I was
just thinking about,
as one of the applications
of the hash function--
so does the hash function
actually replace the data?
So I'm thinking now that
everyone's saving data
in the cloud, so can you
save a hash function instead
of your actual data, and
then so it can be compressed?
GARY GENSLER: Very good
question-- my summary of it--
though others' probably
would be more expert.
My summary is, you get a choice.
You could do either.
So let's take it in blockchain
rather than in the cloud.
You can choose to save in
a blockchain just hashes,
and have the full
picture somewhere else.
Let's say you were going
to do a whole database of--
AUDIENCE: A library.
GARY GENSLER: Of what?
AUDIENCE: I'd say
like a library.
GARY GENSLER: A library--
and so there's 100,000
books in the library.
You could hash
all 100,000 books,
and then store the hashes in
the blockchain and not the books
themselves.
And that would form a
blockchain of the commitments
to those books.
Or you could actually, I
guess, put the books themselves
into the blockchain.
Now, I saw some shaking
heads in the middle.
Alin from the Digital
Currency Initiative.
AUDIENCE: The way I understand
this is, the answer is no.
You can store the hash.
That doesn't replace the data.
The storing of the hash
allows you to prove
that you have the data.
But the fact that
you store the hash
doesn't mean that
you store the data.
GARY GENSLER: But Alin,
there's a two-part question.
You shouldn't get
rid of the book,
because hashes are one way.
You're not able to take the
hash and recreate the look.
You can't take the hash and
recreate The New York Times
crossword puzzle.
But you don't need to store
them in the same place.
Thank you, because it's
two parts the question.
You could store the
hashes in the cloud
and store the books
somewhere else.
But you still need to
store the book, maybe.
So who is Satoshi Nakamoto?
We have just a handful of
minutes, but can every table--
each table's going
to take four minutes.
And amongst yourselves, decide
who is Satoshi Nakamoto.
So how are we doing?
Who's your answer
to Satoshi Nakamoto?
AUDIENCE: We would say,
probably multiple people,
led by Hal Finney.
GARY GENSLER: OK, so the
first one is, multiple people,
probably led by Hal Finney.
AUDIENCE: NSA.
AUDIENCE: Something within the
government or a government.
GARY GENSLER: So table number
2 is, government actor, US
or foreign.
AUDIENCE: I don't know if
it matters, but maybe US.
GARY GENSLER: US, but
it might not matter.
How are we doing over here?
AUDIENCE: Dorian Nakamoto.
GARY GENSLER: Dorian Nakamoto--
so you're going with
the Newsweek story.
Pria, sorry about the
name thing before.
Your table, who--
AUDIENCE: A bunch
of crypto punks.
GARY GENSLER: What's
that, a bunch of crypto--
AUDIENCE: Punks.
GARY GENSLER: Punks.
AUDIENCE: Plus economists--
it's like a group of people.
GARY GENSLER: So a group of
crypto punks and economists.
And how do you spell
crypto punks, though?
AUDIENCE: Cipher punks.
GARY GENSLER: Cipher punks,
cipher punks, actually.
Where are we here?
AUDIENCE: NSA.
GARY GENSLER: Oh,
the NSA, all right.
AUDIENCE: People with
incentive and the capability.
GARY GENSLER: Oh, so
incentives and capability,
you think it's NSA.
AUDIENCE: MIT.
GARY GENSLER: MIT, oh!
AUDIENCE: We said, a
guy named Gary Gensler.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY GENSLER: There
is a word for that,
but I can't say that on tape.
Kelly, Anton, two Alins
what do we have here, Jihee.
AUDIENCE: Let's go
with Nick Szabo.
GARY GENSLER: Nick Szabo,
who wrote the first paper
on smart contracts.
So Aviva is Nick Szabo.
My hash table--
[LAUGHTER]
GARY GENSLER: Who do you go for?
AUDIENCE: We actually
did have him, Szabo.
GARY GENSLER: All
right, you can say
another table for Nick Szabo.
Put another vote next to him.
Here?
AUDIENCE: We're
going with you, Gary.
GARY GENSLER: No, no, come on.
AUDIENCE: We think it's
Craig Steven Wright.
GARY GENSLER: Craig
Wright, the Australian.
Oh, my god.
Oh, Patrick Murck's table
is going to go last.
Here?
AUDIENCE: Bill Belichick.
GARY GENSLER: Bill Belichick.
AUDIENCE: Alan Greenspan.
GARY GENSLER: Alan Greenspan.
I actually know Alan.
He's really talented,
but I don't think
Andrea would let him do this.
Here, who do we have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: Who?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], me.
GARY GENSLER: No, no, but who--
you're saying you invented it?
No, no, this table.
AUDIENCE: This table is
saying he invented it.
GARY GENSLER: Nick Szabo,
so another for Nick Szabo.
So does anybody want to
tell us why it's the NSA?
Oh, Patrick Murck, I'm sorry.
What's this table?
PATRICK MURCK:
Well, I said, if I--
so I don't know.
But if I did know, I would
say that I don't know,
and I would create as much
obfuscation as possible.
So I think I was
the worst person
to have at a table for this.
And I did them nothing but
a disservice in their hunt
for Satoshi.
But I'll let
somebody else speak.
No, I don't know.
GARY GENSLER: But
if he did know,
he would say he doesn't know.
Derek, who did
your table go for?
AUDIENCE: We said Craig Wright.
PATRICK MURCK: You
can see my influence.
GARY GENSLER: Oh, my gosh.
So let me ask this, because
it's just for fun, one minute.
Somebody said that
it was the NSA.
Do you want to say why?
AUDIENCE: Because,
arguably, they
have the most advanced
cryptography in the world.
And if anybody was doing
this, to have a system where
all the dark money in the world
was flowing around instead
of $100 bills, you would create
this and create it in a way
where you could hack it
backwards and figure it out.
And they have the capability.
GARY GENSLER: Wow.
Hugo.
AUDIENCE: More [INAUDIBLE] money
is going through [INAUDIBLE]
right now than it
is through Bitcoin.
GARY GENSLER: So Hugo would
say that, if it was the NSA,
it didn't work out
for them too well.
And those of you who
said Craig Wright,
I heard some others in
the room that said, no.
So who said Craig Wright?
Which two tables
said Craig Wright?
Isabella and Ben, why did
you pick Craig Wright?
AUDIENCE: So I
read a bunch of it.
And basically, people analyzed
the English used in the email,
and they think it traced
back to Australia.
And then we
[INAUDIBLE] from there.
GARY GENSLER: All right, so
just the language analytics
for Craig Wright.
And those who said
it can't possibly
be Craig Wright, who did that?
Alin?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
he started a website.
He said, oh, here's
cryptographic proof
that I'm Satoshi Nakamoto.
But he actually botched it.
Like, if you are
Nakamoto, you can
prove you're Nakamoto by
spending the first coin.
But he couldn't do
that, so come on, man.
GARY GENSLER: So Alin
says, he failed the test.
He didn't spend the
first coins from 2009.
Three tables picked Nick Szabo.
Why'd you pick Nick Szabo, just
any one of the three tables?
Because we're going to talk
about him in the next lecture.
No?
All right, look, this
was a bit of fun.
I just thought it
would be worthwhile.
Because the only
person in the room
that really knows
who Satoshi Nakamoto
is isn't going to tell us.
[LAUGHTER] But you're
welcome back any time.
Thank you.
We'll see you next Tuesday.
Remember, Larry Lessig is here,
so please do the readings.
Please, let's have a good time.